avec vous hélène frade bien sûr
rebonjour pleine bourre jours hélène à
la une de la presse l offensive majeure
lancée en début de semaine de la russie
dans l'est de l'ukraine où moscou c'est
ce que dit la presse en tout cas aurait
déployé entre dix et vingt mille
mercenaires d'après le guardian
effectivement qui cite ici une source
européenne
ces mercenaires envoyés au front sans
armes lourdes ni véhicules blindés
seraient originaires de syrie de libye
mais également appartiendrait au groupe
paramilitaire russe wagner ces hommes
auraient pour mission de s'emparer de
l'est de l'ukraine dans ce qui est
décrit comme une ruée vers une sorte de
victoire dont vladimir poutine espère
pourvoir se targuer lors du défilé
militaire du 9 mai qui commémore en
russie la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale du côté des états unis de new
york times annonce l'envoi d'une
nouvelle aide militaire à l'ukraine à
hauteur de nouveau de 800 millions de
dollars sous la forme d'armes plus
lourdes et plus sophistiquées une
stratégie qui comporte toutefois un
risque notable selon le journal
contrarié la russie au point de le faire
déclencher un conflit international plus
vaste encore un conflit dont le coût
économique n'est pas le même pour tous
les alliés de l'ukraine on apprend à
l'instant avec nous le coût de la guerre
c'est l'union européenne qui le paient
les états unis s'en sortent constate il
fatto quotidiano chiffres du fmi à
l'appui le quotidien italien a relève
qu'au sein de l'eurozone ce sont
l'italie et l'allemagne qui sont les
plus infectés - touché sur le plan
économique les états unis sont par
ailleurs accusé de ne pas tenir leurs
engagements d'accueillir jusqu'à cent
mille réfugiés d'ukrainiens washington
post dénonce le décalage exaspérant je
cite entre les paroles retentissant de
joe biden et la réalité à laquelle sont
confrontés les ukrainiens désespéré qui
tente de se frayer un chemin jusqu'aux
états unis où aucune procédure accélérée
n'a été mise en place contrairement aux
promesses qu'a fait l'administration
bayonne dans la presse également à la
poursuite du bras de fer entre
manifestants et gouvernement hellène au
sri lanka où un protestataire a été tué
hier par la police mado daily mirror
rapporte que deux autre manifestante
également été grièvement blessé
après que la police a ouvert le feu
alors que des dizaines de milliers
d'automobilistes bloqués les routes pour
protester contre la pénurie de carburant
et la hausse des prix pénurie
énergétique mais aussi alimentaire
l'envoyé spécial de mediapart à colombo
raconte le calvaire quotidien des sri
lankais dans un pays dirigé par le clan
rajapaksa qui s'accroche au pouvoir
alors que le sri lanka continue de
s'enfoncer dans la crise la présentation
lundi d'un nouveau gouvernement n'a pas
calmé la colère des manifestants qui
refusent de continuer à payer le prix
entre autres des décisions absurdes du
président gotabaya rajapaksa
d'indécision brute comme cette décision
pardon brutal qu'il a prise l'année
dernière d'interdire l'importation de
fertilisants chimiques pour économiser
des devises étrangères un passage à
l'agriculture biologique sans transition
au pas de charge mais qui s'est avérée
totalement catastrophique pour les
petits paysans quelques mots de la
campagne pour le second tour de la
présidentielle en france avec ce soir le
débat télévisé entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen au fort attendu ce n'est
pas présente la même affiche quand 2017
mais cette fois-ci dixit le parisien les
enjeux sont bien différents en quoi me
demanderez-vous pauline parce que si les
sondages annoncent pour le moment du
moins à une dizaine de points d'écart en
faveur d' emmanuel macron tout resterait
possible pour ce second tour
le président le sait doit réussir le
président sortant doit réussir à
défendre le bilan de son quinquennat et
marine le pen doit pas revenir de son
côté a effacé sa prestation ratée de
2017 l'opinion évoque même le débat de
sa vie pour la candidate du
rassemblement national et le maquereau
et marine le pen que libération espère
voir enfin abordé la question écologique
le tiède et le néant ironise le journal
dont la référence au livre l'être et le
néant et de philosophes français
jean-paul sartre l'enfer c'est les
autres critiquent à la fois le programme
écologique jugé insuffisant des manuels
macro et les propositions inquiétante de
marine le pen libération pauline qui
dégaine envol le bingo
du débat les 20 répliques les plus
attendus avec une petite grille à cocher
au fil de la soirée du côté de marine le
pen notamment peut-être que ça déplaît à
vos amis de mckinsey du côté des manuels
macron entre autres un vous êtes d'une
famille d'un clan qui en huit
présidentielle a défendu les mêmes idées
vous citiez sartre à l'instant hélène je
vais citer sempé qui a signé ce
magnifique recueil qui s'appelle enfance
l'histoire donc vous a parlé en et des
loges avant de vous dira demain
effectivement je vous propose une petite
histoire qui est digne d' easy rider le
film mythique de dennis hopper le dia
lire des séries fait état de la fugue à
moto de deux bambins de 2 ans parvenu
visiblement à déjouer la surveillance du
personnel de leur crèche halle berry à 7
en andalousie une équipée sauvage sur
une moto en plastique à deux ans
forcément ça ne mène pas très loin les
deux petits fugueurs ont été repérés pas
très loin de là 300 mètres feu rouge par
une passante qui évidemment aussitôt
alerté la police celle ci les a ramenés
les crèches est donc bien qui finit bien
la bande originale pour la petite
histoire d' easy rider c'était born to
be wild né pour être sauvage merci
beaucoup hélène c'était la revue de
presse à demain effectivement d'emparé
direct on se retrouve juste après la
pause pour la dernière demi-heure de
cette émission en direct à 18h
[Musique]